[Musique]
dans le cadre de la semaine bleue qui
met à l'honneur les seniors cyrille
melchior vice président du département
souhaité rendre visite au centenaire de
saint paul son canton comme chaque année
l'évolution lui et madame coulandon agit
de 105 ans d'avoir c'est un grand
plaisir pour moi d'aller à la rencontre
de nos centenaires
parce que c'est une chance de les avoir
ce sont des personnes qui ont fait la
réunion et aujourd'hui nous devons le
témoigner de notre affection je dirais
même plus que de l'affection de notre
amour parce que ces personnes ont vécu
va enfin dans des situations difficiles
et aujourd'hui va le département est là
à leurs côtés
depuis l'année dernière elle a perdu un
petit pépin
geithner mais sinon elle va bien elle
mange un petit peu bouillir un petit peu
dur aimé ramond mais elle aime bien le
quart époque gras comme avant ils
n'aiment pas mobile à l'arrêt après moi
ce café petit déjeuner ce que sa journée
la télévision radio freedom est tout
petit enfant qui vient avec elle quand
il alla de la doyenne de saint paul où
la grande fontaine aussi celle fierté
pour nous ses petits-enfants
grâce au département la famille de
madame coulandon a pu réaliser des
travaux dans leur maison afin de
faciliter son quotidien
ma grand-mère retire les tâches pour
monter descendre c'est pas évident donc
ils m'ont aidé à financer cette chambre
et je remercie quand même du conseil
général pour m'aider pour voir tout ça
merci
alors vous êtes bien qu'on adore général
à nyon à moins bon moment il est bien
sûr très bien
[Musique]